everybody experiences hiccups from time
to time I think most people would agree
that one hiccup sort of funny two
hiccups in a row is really funny and
three hiccups in a row is where it
starts to be concerning in part because
hiccups can be kind of painful there is
a technique that can reliably eliminate
hiccups and it's a technique that takes
advantage of hyper Contracting the
frenic nerve over a short period of time
so that it then subsequently relaxes or
alleviates the spasming of the fr nerve
and that simple method is to inhale
three times in a row this is a very
unusual pattern of breathing but what it
involves is take a big deep inhale
through your nose then before you exhale
any air take a second inhale through the
nose however brief that inhale might be
and then a third even micro or
millisecond long inhale through your
nose to get that third inhale and then
hold your breath for about 15 to 20
seconds and then slowly exhale